DON DODGE: Hi.
I'm Don Dodge.
And this is Google
Root Access.
Today I'm in London at the
Google Campus, a startup
facility here for many,
many startups.
And I'm here today with
Eze Vidra, the
manager of the campus.
EZE VIDRA: Hi, Don.
Thanks for having me.
My name is Eze Vidra.
And I'm the head of Campus
here in London.
And it's my pleasure to
introduce you to the Campus
London community.
DON DODGE: So, Eze, tell me
about Campus London and how it
got started and what it is.
EZE VIDRA: Sure.
Usually the way that I describe
Campus, if there was
an equivalent between real
estate and software, Campus
would be an open source
building.
It's like an API for startups,
which means it's a seven story
building in East London that's
filled with startups.
Like any operating system or
open source system, it would
be boring if one company
did all the apps.
So we work with multiple
partners and with the
community to power the startup
ecosystem in London.
DON DODGE: So incubators and
accelerators are pretty common
around the world.
Is there any difference
here in London?
Or is it about the same?
EZE VIDRA: I would say that
generally, the accelerators
follow the same program
or the same template.
There's many startups
that apply.
Some of them get selected.
And then the lucky ones
receive mentorship and
investment and support.
We have seed camp.
We have springboard.
We have [INAUDIBLE]
ventures, Entrepreneur First.
There's an explosion of programs
coming out of London.
And I'm happy to say that
they're going really well.
So there's lots of them
involved in Campus as
partners, and you can see them
rotate every three months on
the third floor.
DON DODGE: And what is Google's
involvement in Campus London?
EZE VIDRA: So we run several
programs and initiatives to
support startups and help them
get visibility, mentorship
skills, and education.
Our umbrella program is called
Campus EDU, and it has three
sections to it.
One is office hours, where every
Friday, Googlers come to
campus to provide mentorship
for the startups.
We've been doing it for the
last 10 months, and we had
over 350 startups that receive
mentorship and over 200
Googlers that mentored.
This is anything from Android
to recruiting to technical
advice, et cetera.
And it's been going
really well.
The second part is inspirational
talks, bringing
thought leaders like Eric
Schmidt, Jimmy Wales, or Guy
Kawasaki to inspire the startups
in different talks
that we hold for the residents
and members of Campus.
And finally, we're launching
in May the classes part in
collaboration with different
universities and corporate
partners, giving startups the
education that they need when
they need it.
And also mixing these two
groups that they're very
important for one another.
One is the students
on one hand.
And the other one is the
startups in the field.
DON DODGE: So Google purchased
this building in East London?
Is that right?
EZE VIDRA: We took a
long lease on this
building in East London.
Yeah.
DON DODGE: OK.
And Google's providing the
building for this?
And the startups come
here for free?
Or how does that work?
EZE VIDRA: Sure.
So Campus is the not for profit
activity for Google.
I run a P&L. But I always
jokingly say that it's mostly
L.
And what we did is we took a
long lease on the building, we
renovated it, and then we
partnered with multiple
partners to operate different
parts of the building.
So on the lower floor, we have
a cafe that's an open space
for entrepreneurs,
with fast Wi-Fi.
Any entrepreneur can sign
up and work from
the cafe for free.
And that's essentially like a
Starbucks filled with startups.
There's over 12,000 people that
have registered to work
from the cafe.
That's operated by
Central Working.
And then we have two floors of
co-working space operated by
our partner TechHub
where startups can
simply rent a desk.
Then we have accelerator
programs that we rotate every
three months.
And then we have Seedcamp
startup weekend and Kodak,
which is a union trade for
startups, if you will.
DON DODGE: Great.
Yes, so I saw Seedcamp was
here, and TechHub .
They've been ongoing
for a while.
So they joined into Campus
to do their programs?
EZE VIDRA: Yeah, so we decided
on a partnership approach when
we launched Campus to leverage
the experience and the
goodwill of basically the
partners that have been most
active in the scene in London.
So rather than dropping in on
East London and trying to
reinvent the wheel, or compete
with local players, we
partner with them.
And it's been going
really well.
Actually, what we're seeing
is that as an open source
building, we not only generate
all the community activity
from our own events and our
own networks, but we also
bring in all of this experience
and passion from
other people.
So you can see events from any
of the partners and from the
community, ranging from
community meetups, like tech
meetups on PHP or big data to
hack-a-thons over the weekend.
And it's just incredible
to see that range.
We had over 60,000 people
in year one
attending the events alone.
And we hosted 868 events
in year one.
DON DODGE: Wow.
That's a lot.
How many companies are
actually here?
EZE VIDRA: So we've helped
over 1,000 startups since
we've launched Campus
a year ago.
There's over 100 startups
working from Campus everyday.
And that's ranging from the cafe
to the co-working areas
to the third floor to Seedcamp
startups, et cetera.
So it's very fluid because every
now and then you would
see a delegation of startups
doing a pilgrimage to Campus
just to pitch on the
Campus stage.
So at any given point, you can
have 20 startups coming from
Belgium or from Korea simply
to get involved with the
Campus community.
DON DODGE: So that's an
interesting point.
Campus is sort of a catalyst
to bring together investors
and startups and resources
and mentors.
So how many events are you
doing every month?
EZE VIDRA: So in February alone,
we hosted 133 events.
In April, now, we're celebrating
the Campus one
year anniversary.
And every day there's a
major event going on.
So today, for example, it was
a pleasure to have you speak
at the Investor Open Day, which
attracted the whole VC
community and angel community
in London, to come and see
what we're doing
at the Campus.
So it's quantity, but it's also
the quality of events.
I think it's unparalleled
anywhere in the world the
number of entrepreneurship and
startup events we do here on a
daily basis.
DON DODGE: And I think today you
announced a new thing to
bring in investors.
How often are you going
to do that?
EZE VIDRA: That's correct.
So we identified that investment
is a key part, a
key interest, of the
startups at Campus.
But we haven't done anything
actively to attract investors
until now, although 50% of the
Campus residents told us that
they met with investors
at Campus.
So today, we launched the Campus
Capitol Office Hours,
bringing investors every two
weeks for office hours, and
then having them essentially
using meritocracy,
participating, mentoring the
startups and giving them
inspiration and skills.
And then the investors that
participate in the office
hours will get invited to a
Campus Demo Day periodically,
twice a year, where they
can see a bunch of
companies in one go.
Similar to Y Combinator, except
it doesn't have the
program around it.
DON DODGE: So if I have an
idea and I'm working with
another engineer putting
it together, how
do I get into Campus?
Should I submit to Seedcamp
or to TechHub?
What's the process
for getting in?
EZE VIDRA: So as an API for
startups, there's multiple
ways, multiple calls you
can make to the API.
Most people start
from the cafe.
It's full everyday.
It's free.
All you have to do is register
on CampusLondon.com, and you
can work for free in the cafe.
If you have a little bit of
money, you can rent a desk and
essentially participate
in a co-working space.
Rather than getting your own
office and try to kit it with
internet connection, printers,
et cetera, you can simply rent
a desk for a nominal fee, and
you're surrounded by a
community and you're
in business.
Shared conference rooms,
et cetera.
Other people apply to
Accelerator programs.
It really depends on the
stage of your startup.
If you're in the early days of
the startup, and you're a
first time founder, Seedcamp
or one of the Accelerator
programs are a great way to
receive this mentorship and
avoid some typical mistakes that
can cost you the startup.
And then if you're not really
sure that you want to be an
entrepreneur, I would recommend
that you join a
hack-a-thon or a startup weekend
event, where you can
really feel the teamwork, the
creativity, and the time
pressure of building a startup
in 54 hours without
quitting your job.
So there's many ways that
people can participate.
And we see it every day.
DON DODGE: So you've
seen hundreds of
startups already at Campus.
Are you seeing any trends or
things you're interested in?
EZE VIDRA: You know, that's a
really interesting question.
The majority of the startups at
Campus are early stage web
and mobile, mainly consumer
applications.
We've been seeing an increase
of hardware startups.
For example, there's a startup
that's making a mobile phone
touch screen made of bamboo.
It uses Android as an
operating system.
But the casing of the phone
is made of wood, and it's
ecologically friendly,
et cetera.
There's another hardware startup
that's created a bike
light for bicycle riders
to prevent
the blind spot problem.
So if you're a bus, you probably
couldn't see the bike
coming next to you.
And it causes lots of deaths
every year in London.
Now with this light, it projects
a laser on the floor,
and the bus driver is able to
see the bike from far away.
These startups are raising
funding through Kickstarter,
which has really changed all
the hardware landscape, I
would say, for consumers.
And then other trends include
advertising technology.
Lots of the big agencies
are here.
And we're seeing some
destructive Ad-Tech companies.
For example, there's a
multi-device startup that's
just raised a million in seed,
part of the Entrepreneur First
accelerator program that we
hosted for three months.
[? Avocarot, ?]
that's trying to basically fix
the problem of display
advertising on mobile and
do context-specific ads.
So when you finish a run,
it'll show you an ad for
Lucozade, or for some sort of
drink, versus showing you the
ad for an online game.
So I would say advertising
technology, definitely.
Financial technology is another
big trend in London.
But generally speaking, I think
the startup ecosystem in
London is in a stage where
we're throwing a lot of
spaghetti on the wall, and
we're seeing what sticks.
But I think that eventually
we'll converge to Fin Tech, Ad
Tech, fashion in the areas of
London as an industry has very
strong presence.
DON DODGE: So Financial
Tech, advertising
technology, and fashion.
Those are three that seem
to be pretty big here?
EZE VIDRA: Yeah.
And gaming also has a big
presence, although there's
other pockets of gaming
in Europe
that maybe are stronger.
You know, in the Nordics
or in the north of
Scotland, as well.
DON DODGE: Any companies
that you've seen--
you mentioned a couple--
that you're interested in, that
you think are leading?
EZE VIDRA: I'll tell you one
company that I'm excited about
and one company that has an
interesting story from Campus.
So one that I'm excited about
is called Eyetease.
And they're putting Wi-FI
into London cabs.
And the way that they're paying
for it is by installing
an LCD screen on the roof of the
cab that enables you to do
real time geo-located
advertising.
So when the cab is passing next
to a McDonald's, you're
able to show them a very
specific ad for that moment.
So as a user, I'm really excited
to have Wi-Fi in cabs.
And that's why I'm excited
about this startup.
There is a company called
Subscrib, where the founders
actually met in the cafe and
they were thinking about--
at the cafe at Campus-- and they
were thinking about, how
can we improve the loyalty
between brick and mortar
retailers and their customers?
You know,when you go to an
e-commerce site, they
know who you are.
They are able to email you
and call you back.
But when you go to a physical
store, you just pay cash and
you're anonymous to them.
So they created a
loyalty scheme.
They managed to implement it in
the cafe downstairs, where
users pay 40 pounds at the
beginning of the month, and
then they get 50 pounds value
in products in the cafe.
They did really well.
They rented a desk on TechHub.
They spent a couple of months
in the co-working space.
They applied to Seedcamp.
And in four months, this company
now has a product,
revenues, customers.
And they would never be where
they are today if it wasn't
for Campus.
So I really like that story.
DON DODGE: All right.
Great story.
Another story, Babelverse.
I saw them--
I think they were a Startup
Weekend company.
And I saw them at Tech Crunch
Disrupt last year.
And I saw them here today.
I was kind of surprised.
EZE VIDRA: Yeah.
Babelverse is an interesting
one.
As you mentioned, it's a Startup
Weekend company.
The founders met in
a Startup Weekend.
They actually come from
very different places.
They met in a Startup
Weekend in Greece.
But none of them is Greek.
And they are providing a
marketplace for interpreters,
for real person interpreters.
So it's a founding team of three
people, but they have
thousands of people around the
world collaborating with them
in a crowdsourcing way.
And right now, they're spending
six weeks at Campus
as part of a competition we
ran, offering startups at
Campus six weeks of free office
space on the third
floor between programs, between
Accelerator programs.
So I'm really excited about
having them here.
Also sharing their experience
from the different stops they
did around the world and
participating in all the
activities we offer.
DON DODGE: Another company,
Summly, has
been in the news recently.
It's a UK-based company.
A 17-year-old high school kid
started the company and Yahoo
just acquired it.
So that's not a Campus
London story.
But it's a London story.
EZE VIDRA: Yeah.
You know, it makes me feel
bad about what I was
doing when I was 17.
But they don't drop out
of college anymore.
They're dropping out of high
school to start companies.
But Nick D'Aloisio
is the founder.
And it's a really interesting
story because I think it's a
reminder that exits, or
disruptive technology, can
come from anywhere
and from anyone.
So Nick D'Aloisio created this
app that enables you to
summarize text by shaking
your phone.
So you can take any article, you
shake the phone, and then
you receive a short
summary that's
the gist of the article.
And I guess with Yahoo's focus
on content in advertising,
it's core to their strategy.
And the startup after a year and
a half of operation in a
small seed investment from
[? Horizon's ?] ventures, as
far as I know, and maybe a
couple more VCs, just exited
for $20, $30 million.
So not huge, but still a
reminder that entrepreneurship
is a career choice for graduates
and college students
and high school students.
And also that exits can come
out of London, as well.
DON DODGE: So you had a great
first year at Campus London,
created it from nothing a year
ago, and now have hundreds of
startups here and thousands
of events.
What's next?
EZE VIDRA: It's a
great question.
You know, when we established
Campus, there was lots of
suspicion and conspiracy
theories of, why is Google
doing this?
And we're doing this to
invest in startups.
We're doing is to buy
startups for cheap.
And that's not the reason
for doing Campus.
We're doing it to help
the ecosystem grow.
And I would love to see us
continue that mission,
focusing on education
and community.
So, so far we've been great for
the physical community.
People if they're able to come
to the building and take
advantage of the facilities
and the
services that we provide.
And next, I would like to level
the playing field and
offer these sort of mentorship
and skills to entrepreneurs
around the world.
So we are in the process of
installing cameras in the
event spaces.
With the Campus EDU program, we
will record each event and
made it available on the
Campus YouTube channel.
And I hope that with time, we
will be able to bring together
entrepreneurs, regardless of
where they're physically
located, and serve as thought
leadership or brain trust for
them to bounce ideas, to talk to
each other, and to get the
access to mentorship,
inspiration, and skills.
DON DODGE: So Google is doing
this as a public investment
just to stimulate the
startup ecosystem
and support the economy?
EZE VIDRA: Absolutely.
And I think that's the right
way to look at it.
This is not CSR.
We didn't just put the building
and said, here you
go, community.
Just have it.
It's an investment.
And we're putting a lot of
resource and support in making
this work, and helping the
startups get traction,
visibility, and mentorship.
Last year, or two years now,
we established Google for
Entrepreneurs as an umbrella
organization to support
entrepreneurs wherever they
are around the world.
And Campus is maybe the biggest
manifestation of
Google for Entrepreneurs.
It's a seven story building in
East London that supports the
local startup community.
But I think more and more, we're
seeing these communities
bind together.
Two months ago, we launched
Campus Tel Aviv.
We're doing initiatives in
Berlin and in Paris to support
partners who are running these
sort of initiatives.
And I would like to see more of
that collaboration across
countries, between
entrepreneurs.
That they're trying to solve a
problem, disrupt technology,
and change the world with it.
DON DODGE: Excellent.
Well thank you very much for
being with me today and
telling us the story
of Campus.
And be with us again next week
when we talk about another
topic of interest to startups.
Thanks.
EZE VIDRA: Thank you.